all right so this is Simon and Marcy
this is finally going into a little bit
more detail about a Marceline and the
Ice King in the past history they had
together it starts off with them playing
basketball with Finn and Jake and they
ask why do you invite Ice King along and
it says was it 996 years earlier was
that it - the day - the day and they go
there and we see that there's it's
obviously right after the apocalypse and
there's some sort of it's not zombies
it's more jelly donuts with the jelly
coming out of their eyes
creatures going around I don't know what
they are but they're it's very walking
dead and it just sort of shows how
they're trying to you know survive with
each other you know and then how Simon's
obviously raising Marceline he's not
crazy yet and she's making a promise not
to put the crown on because he goes too
far and by the end he hasn't totally
succumbed yet he's still he's still
Simon and he's afraid to put back on but
you know it's he still seems to be
himself and then the Ice King makes like
a million goals with his basketball
because that's all it matters to him now
uh I suppose this really quickly do not
get excited people going what go what go
on okay honestly I thought this episode
delivered just what I expected and that
kind of let me down I was actually I
think because it it's not bad but again
it's all like those episodes before
there's nothing wrong with it's not bad
it's just man they leaving it more to
your imagination what they went through
and him slowly falling apart you know to
have this be what they deliver it and
like I said it's sort of every
apocalyptic zombie survival movie show
comic whatever that you see and you know
accept this with these characters and to
me it felt like decent every
you know it felt like average fanfiction
yes or what it felt like and I guess I
was really expecting something just like
totally different until I like you know
wow what is the story what is it and
it's sort of exactly what I thought it
was gonna be and that's not bad but for
a show I that's really so good at just
surprising the hell out of me and I
thought it was I thought it's just all
right that's why I said be don't don't
get excited people this is the woman and
she got me teary-eyed but then and I'll
tell you why
for me it's you're saying it was okay at
the end he wasn't though
because remember he grabs cuz he puts
the crown on and he says he calls
Marceline Gunter already yeah I do that
what it bells beside has seemed to me at
but every winter when you notice he's
coming down his glasses are off he
doesn't even attempt to pick them up and
he goes in to hug her and like says you
know you're probably getting better
she's like I love you Simon and he goes
I love you to Gunther oh oh you know
what I actually miss that so he empties
says Gunther at the end yeah finally
gone past that point okay like that
really hit me plus for me it was also
you can say those kids kind of like all
the other post-apocalyptic but at the
same time I felt it was a lot more like
heartwarming where he's like here let's
watch a movie and say pick up the VHS
tape but they just look at it
really boring movie I like yeah I mean
the TV that the connection is definitely
there it's not that it's not there or
that it's badly dot I mean it is well
done i jus did miss where you call the
gun turrets and I caught it at the
beginning but no that actually that's
that doesn't make it a bit better but
for me I was when he started singing the
the cheers thing when he was trying to
keep it together and it's like just
imagine you're a that's the only thing
you can do to possibly keep your sanity
I do like the fact that's like yeah that
like the cheers song yeah like suddenly
this you know what's gonna mental
you it's just that beat I just see like
the people wrote the song like you know
just like you you want the copyright to
the song to do what well this Ice King
puts on its head and it so he can
remember that he signed it while he
saves this little demon girl from these
apocalyptic Donuts they're bleeding
jelly and tried to attack him as a
fighter
okay just write us a check yeah no
that's one thing I noticed personally
when I was younger
even was a kid I noticed in like it to
me it fit this episode very much those
all theme songs were pretty freakin
depressing good times
oh my god last I ride cuz it's called
good time do you think at least the
theme song with the upbeat exactly and
that's the thing it's one it's a dark
theme like oh god Archie Bunker all the
family yeah okay yeah Tech the theme to
taxi has no lyrics
but if you listen to it it's actually
kind of like depressing it's not really
depressing it's unbelievably depressed
and then if you listen to the cheers one
it's like where do you want to go yes
the place where everyone knows your name
you gotta gather but if you know
connected with the show and how
depressing that show could actually be
well that stay place in a bar bunch of
people who are trying to escape reality
well you even be opening with like the
line drawings instead this are like well
this is how it used to be and this is
how it is now yes like yeah I mean
there's there's so true to that it's
like a similar over-the-top feel good
like Full House or perfect strangers and
stuff but you're right I started the
ones that are a bit more at all there
was served like this bittersweet feeling
to them that's how I got when Simon was
singing it it was that bittersweet of I
need to do this to protect it like this
little kid that I love but I know I'm
going to lose myself in the process and
it fit this song for me with the whole
bittersweet I mean I've seen all these
post-apocalyptic movies and stuff like
that where it kind of makes me yawn
after a while oh yeah they you know the
guys totally caring for you know the
child and all that stuff you gotta gotta
gotta put it in the end you see they're
fine this is one of those where it's not
that see to me and I lost it I I would I
mean it's nice thing that
you'll come up another episode I want to
see what happens after he calls her gum
to her gum yeah it's like that is like
okay that's gonna be the new stuff and
that's gonna be the really fascinating
stuff but you know before that it's sort
of like like you said sort the typical
apocalyptic story um but like I do like
the Gunther then the first time he calls
her Gunther I just felt uneasy I was
just like I mean the Rory I mean that's
the one moment I was like yeah that was
you know that matches sort of the
uncomfortableness of the I remember you
episode yeah you know and I can't
believe that this way at the end but I
mean knowing the best parts - yeah but
that's just like that's just as
depressing it just as good it's like so
I mean I guess you can say that sort of
bookends it for me and a lot of besides
it's it's not bad it's really not
because like the connection is there you
know and curly - what do you think well
I mean you guys pretty much set it all
you took care of this no you guys said I
mean I am more with Jason this really
bothered me a lot actually it's I mean
you're right in the sense it hits
everything that you would expect
including a cleanse I mean you have a
good point with that but at the same
time for me I guess I got all worked up
and sucked in in that I wasn't just
looking at it as okay there's this
episode this is what's happening it was
more like oh Jesus Christ
Marcy and Simon and seeing the way it
was really nice and sad but really nice
to see cuz you got that sense that
they're connected and obviously we know
Simon took care of Marcy when she was
little and that's why she's connected to
him blah blah blah but seeing it happen
is different than just knowing it
matically you see the little things that
he did for her
I mean silly things you know I mean even
just you know well she doesn't want to
be picked up but he wants to carry her
because she's sick and he's all like I'm
old I'm like a bajillion years old and I
would totally do it if someone offered
to pick me up like he's just doing all
these great nice things and she's doing
like the proper parental things actually
you know when Jason's absolutely right -
it's so bittersweet because you kind of
feel you see and you feel he knows he
shouldn't put it on he promised her it's
heartbreaking because he does he looks
right before he puts it on at the end
you know he has no choice what is he
gonna do 30 you can't fight them off but
then you're breaking your promise to
this little girl what do you do how do
you work it either way
her heart is broken either she's gonna
get hurt or you break your promise to
her and probably lose her but you'll
know she's safe well I don't heavy I was
gonna say it I don't even think it's a
matter of getting her I think it's a
matter of like they would both die you
know I mean jazz they would be lost at
ease yeah donut people yeah you know so
I mean yeah there's just absolutely no
way out of it
you know and like I said it's it's a
it's all fine I really do want emphasize
that it really is fine you know it is
though like best example I can think of
is when I saw Batman Begins when they're
talking about bad maybe gives out saying
I don't wanna know what happened to
Bruce Wayne after the parents were shot
leave it to the imagination don't ruin
it come I leave but what happened I
thought had something twists and turns
and insert different elements it's like
what's he doing in Alaska what he's a
ninja malyshev is bad and it's like but
what's really fascinating and I got
really into it and I love it when
something takes something that I think
it's gonna go one direction not only
takes a different direction but makes it
better and you know for me else are like
okay that that's our won me over and
with this I serve felt like you know I I
think just sort of what you like the
unknown I felt with better in this case
at least in this episode I want to just
say this really quickly and it sounds
incredibly bizarre when I say it this
way
and I'm aware that it sounds bizarre
Batman
is I've never been a huge fan of Batman
to begin with okay you know I haven't
Batman Begins I actually enjoyed though
it's one few that I did enjoy
but I guess Batman Begins took it hear
me out before his comments almost took
it more from the fantasy standpoint this
episode took it more from a very real
standpoint yes they were zombies with
goo coming out of their eyes or whatever
I understand that but what I'm saying
it's they were human beings on the run
kind of stuck in a bad situation
Batman was just being Batman well round
fighting and learning how to fight and
stuff it that's what I'm saying like
this seemed to take it from a more
humanistic standpoint of we're just
trying to survive we're trying to get
through it I think I see you're saying
where I mean with because I know a lot
of people are gonna be like but one is
fantasy you one is natural versus wait
up I think I think I don't you're
talking about with like you know with
Batman it's like I'm becoming you know
the superhero I'm going to Train like a
ninja I'm going to blob apply that not
not too many people if a person can
identify with losing their parents not
too many people can identify with going
to a laughs gonna train wind in just
coming back getting a bad suit and stuff
like that where with this you know even
though it's a completely out there
scenario it's still surviving being on
your own it's the interaction off the
people and stuff like that
you know which will lead to the
goofiness also you know fun but yes I
see what you saying when it took it much
more humanistic approach uh yeah and
there's lots of stuff now I've seen
where it's like I know the cliches in
this story and I know practically
everything that's gonna happen but you
know whatever the characters or the
delivery or something carries me through
and I really really love it yeah and my
guess is that's probably what it sounds
like you guys are on board without sure
other people are too because I could
totally sympathize with that you know
it's like okay I can watch a certain
movie and just be like okay I know every
single thing that's gonna happen but by
god I love watching these people you
know watching these characters uh and
they were very nice you know to see him
interact off each other so no I can I
can totally see that
well sorry wonderful I have to say it I
have to say it uh it looks like that was
the beginnings of bubblegum did you
notice who gave him the chicken suit to
give to Marcy was that pink blob I said
trust the fungus I'm surprised none of
you jumped on man no I was waiting till
we were done so because after that is
one key feature and he's calls her
Gunther that's why I kept my mouth shut
I didn't want you to miss that even
though he did I was too busy making my
dress the fungus joke no if you look
it's dropped down and then as he's like
picking it up there's kind of the face I
meant reassurance bubblegum this is my
prediction she is made out of some sort
of pinks that we've seen her like you
know when I take her hair and it's pink
or something like that or when she was
ya know less sticky if you think about
it when he was first climbing up that
web to the clambulance yeah it was my
ambulance um it was kind of sticky and
then when they were falling down when he
was holding Marcy his backpack got stuck
on it and that's right I told him hang
in there for a little bit before they
fell down but the backpack was still
stuck up you know what's so funny it
just it didn't it doesn't even clip I
think you're right yeah I I think it's
like yeah what's a little smile and
everything well that would possibly
explain I mean we saw that like
bubblegum and Marceline had some sorry
history yesterday I really want to know
even more like how bubblegum comes to be
because she she was this black thing no
I never would have thought but you're
right no I do this you're probably dead
on me it's like I haven't seen the show
so I mean I'm sure people be like yes
but ya know I actually that's it sounds
right it sounds incredibly right
so comments on that Jason so for the
record yes this is the one that actually
pretty much made me cry it's broke it
really it it's damn kids show you
shouldn't go into something this
depressing and this like heartbreaking
in a kid show you know I mean it's great
I think it's great that they're doing it
but it's so unexpected for me for me
that was I remember you that really was
the one that's like oh yeah I didn't
quite get teary I mean it was just like
I mean with all right yeah it's just
like I can't believe like you said I
just can't believe this is it in a kids
show they're doing something this happy
I mean what show you know takes this
long a time just to see two people you
know dealing with the fact that one has
completely lost their mind and their
memory and it was someone they loved and
they're letting that person go it's like
yikes I mean even something like you
know whatever Batman animated series are
like you know avatars I mean some of my
favorite shows I mean I can't think of
one that was just like we're just gonna
sit here and we're gonna see these two
people talk and we're gonna see how one
you know is letting go of the other and
has to let go of the other this
incredible tragedy just through talking
you know and even singing and and it's
supposed to be Ice King I'm the vampire
demon Queen and there it's like friggin
heartbreak yeah cool though in a way
because I love it it keeps it keeps the
parents entertained the parents wanting
to watch more you can first of all this
could turn into like a family thing not
just like oh the kids are watching this
and the parents are watching this and
whatever whatever it's a genuine family
thing that everybody can look forward to
and then when you come to these episodes
where they're happy or they're serious
what a great opportunity because when
the hell are you gonna sit down with
your kids really really okay kids it's
our weekly session of talking about
serious stuff it's all timers time hey
grandma doesn't remember you
you know they meet but it's kind of its
kind of really great for me it's a
teaching moment I know but it is it's a
nice teaching moment that kind of feels
a little bit more natural it's a great
way to kind of discuss things yeah the
kids don't catch it they don't catch it
if the kids ask or they say hahaha you
can kind of bring it up and I think it's
really a brilliant way to do a show now
see for me this is a brand by the way I
was schooled in the comments section on
Pixar films and I want to say thank you
by the way to that but no um this is one
reason example of why I'm not a fan of
Disney films Disney has the kick humor
and has the adult humor but they're at
such like polar opposites the kid humor
has to be kind of like dick and fart
jokes where it's just stupid stupid
stupid humor and the adult things have
to be so dark and so this there's no
good middle ground in modern Disney
films that I've seen like the older ones
they had kind of a better grasp on the
balance between the two and it's like at
some point in time maybe like a Ladner a
little bit before head it started that
rift up we need to have adult humor in
this now we can't just have you know at
a kid's movie we have to now pull in the
adult audience we have to do that and I
think that's where it broke me it was
one of those like I don't need to you
know hear adult humor in a kid's movie
and it kind of bothers me and annoys me
and it feels incredibly cheap if I have
to see I'll say if I have to see one
more animated climax where it's like
okay the bill to the climax then the
goofy sidekicks doing their thing and
then the really heavy moment between the
here on the mountain that I was so sick
of the goofy moment before as you always
know it's coming it's like when they
first did it okay we haven't see it
second time all right kinda like the
last one but whatever and then it's in
every student movie and I really do is
just I hated waiting for that like yeah
we know the thick can we just get to
but good climatic fit they can't make a
movie that's just kind of like goofy
slowly getting serious and I'm kind of
serious they always have to have that or
they always have to have a sexual joke
so they have to have and it just feels
like it's pandering to every possible
audience that it possibly can and none
of the ideas ever become truly cohesive
and this is a kids show where it seems
to have that balance down and there
seems to be really good at getting the
adult to humor the kid humor the dick
and fart jokes the touching moments done
properly you know and that's me though
and don't hate me hate me because I need
Disney hey well I was going to say even
with the you know the stuff that goes
into you know the really goofy or the
really adult um you know in various
certainly you said there's this nice
segue into them and never as much as I
love Batman the Animated Series and even
to some extent avatar if there is sort
of this sense of okay we're gonna be
this episode and we're gonna be this
kind of episode with Adventure Time it's
sort of like well I don't know no I
haven't that episode that the one the
Christmas one where they're building up
you know well I know and then suddenly
that atom bomb of drama you know it's
like no you can do that and you can do
it successfully but you can also say
wait and it seems like it just sort of
does everything and in experiments and
it dies out stuff and even when it
doesn't work it's like never that bad
that's why I always feel bad whenever
I'm like you know yeah this is just okay
or something but it's felt great
compared to like what every other
animated show is doing yeah you know so
it's still unbelievably impressive so
yeah we probably talked yeah this is
another I remember I can't believe you
watched it okay no no no I'm gonna get
clubbed to death time so what can I say
a glitch is a glitch
really you're a terrible at these segues
I know yes stop reading